GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
>> THE PLEASURE IS MINE.
>> Tucker: SEAN DAVIS IS THE
COFOUNDER OF THE FEDERALIST
COMPANY JUST WROTE A GREAT PIECE
DESCRIBING THE COLLUSION DEBACLE
AS A CATASTROPHIC MEDIA FAILURE
AND EVEN THAT MAY BE AN
UNDERSTATEMENT.
IF YOU'RE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM JOIN
US TONIGHT.
AS YOU WROTE THIS PIECE YOU
OBVIOUSLY COLLECTED WHAT YOU
BEEN WATCHING AND THINKING ABOU
ABOUT.
HOW BIG WAS YOUR CONCLUSION WITH
THE MAGNITUDE OF THESE GREW UP
HERE?
>> THIS IS PROBABLY THE BIGGEST,
MOST CONSEQUENTIAL SCREWUP OF
THE LAST 25 OR 50 YEARS.
IT IS DIFFICULT TO REALLY
COMPREHEND OR OVERSTATE THE
DAMAGE THAT THE MEDIA DID TO THE
COUNTRY INTO THEIR OWN
REPUTATION TO THE CONSTITUTION.
THIS WAS AN ABSOLUTE CATASTROPH
CATASTROPHE.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW ANY --
I KNOW LIBERALS WOULD FEEL THAT
WAY.
I DON'T KNOW ANYBODY RUNNING A
MEDIA ORGANIZATION ON THE LEFT
WHO WAS COMMITTING TO ADMIT IT.
THE EDITOR TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND JEFF
ZUCKER OF CNN, ALL BRAGGING
ABOUT WHAT A GREAT JOB THEY DID.
HOW COULD THEY SAY THAT?
>> I WOULDN'T SAY, THEY WERE
GIVEN PULITZERS?
THEY WERE SHOWERED WITH
ADULATION BY THEIR PEERS AND
ABLE TO PAT EACH OTHER ON THE
BACK AND TELL THEM THAT THEY
WERE HEROES.
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BRING DOWN
THE NEXT PRESIDENT AND HOLD HIM
ACCOUNTABLE.
THERE IS NO INCENTIVE IN THE
MEDIA FOR THEM TO HAVE GONE THIS
RIGHT.
ALL THE INCENTIVES THE WRONG
DIRECTION, VIEWERSHIP OR
IDEOLOGY.
THERE WAS NO REASON FOR THEM TO
GET THIS RIGHT.
>> Tucker: THE MUELLER REPORT
COMES OUT SUNDAY AFTERNOON AND
THE NEXT DAY SHOWS CNN AND MSNBC
DROP BY AS MUCH AS 50%
VIEWERSHIP, JUST ON THE NEWS.
DOES THAT TELL YOU EVERYTHING
ABOUT THEIR INCENTIVE TO PRETEND
THAT THERE IS COLLUSION?
THEIR AUDIENCE GOES AWAY WITHOUT
IT.
>> ABSOLUTELY AND WE SAW THE
REACTION, A CHILDREN WHINING OF
THE TOOTH FAIRY ISN'T REAL.
THEIR BREAD AND BUTTER IN THE
AGE OF TRUMP IS TO RATCHET UP
THE HYSTERIA TO GET PEOPLE
COMPLETELY FREAKED OUT SO THEY
FEEL THEY HAVE TO WATCH THE NEWS
EVERY DAY AND EVERY MINUTE TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT IS GOING ON.
THEY DID A HUGE DISSERVICE TO
THEIR COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: IT IS HARD TO KNOW
WHAT COMES NEXT IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT.
I MEAN, WHEN THE SMOKE CLEARS
AND TRUMP IS GONE OR WHATEVER
HAPPENS IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
WHERE'D YOU GO FOR NEWS?
WILL ANYONE EVER BELIEVE CNN
ASSUMING IT STILL EXISTS FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST" OR
"THE NEW YORK TIMES"?
HOW COULD YOU?
>> THAT IS THEIR PROBLEM.
THEY DIDN'T JUST DESTROY THEIR
OWN REPUTATIONS.
FOR ALL THE TALK THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAS ERODED AND
DAMAGED HER VITAL NORMS AND
INSTITUTIONS.
IT IS THE MEDIA WHO LET IT
CREDENCE TO HIS CHARGE.
IT IS THE MEDIA THEMSELVES WHO
BROADCAST EVERYONE, YOU DON'T
NEED TO TRUST US.
WE ARE NOT TRUSTWORTHY.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY COME BACK
FROM THIS.
>> Tucker: IF YOU DON'T WANT
TO BE CALLED A LIAR THAN STOP